[Music]
in fabricated life news oh you too
submitted by a big fat kakapo crazy duck
barks the tables turned on a man who
posted a fake stalking story on
Instagram big stalking story not like a
Christmas stocking both of you said cuz
trying to pay attention but I heard her
stupid David you look so crated a cocker
spaniel
let you do Oh kakapo yeah I thought it
was that there's a bird too - OH -
cocker spaniel okay so did you all hear
the headline yeah yeah no I got it I
think you're the only one who's sitting
next to her that didn't hear it I didn't
hear it but I know what she said cuz I
wrote it
it was like a man figured out how to
make brisket no no the tables turned on
a man who posted a fake stalking story
on Instagram trying to stalk you if you
ain't famous bro man I wonder what it
feels like to be stopped this dude try
to stop me when I was 16 though like
from a good-ass time like I gave out my
real phone number cuz I didn't know how
to reject people when they're hitting on
you and those like this 28 year old dude
cuz I just worked at a bar and I gave in
my number I was like I worked at a bar
or 16 yeah it was like a bar girl yeah
cuz he was like being really nice all
night and I didn't know at that time how
to like just change one digit later but
like after this guy I learned he thought
I learned to not reject oh yeah yeah and
I always change that one digit that one
digit doesn't work I think the other
person will just try the tenon no no you
changed the middle digit oh that's mine
Dave him your number
that means you showed interest and then
he's still stalk but I told him I had a
boyfriend and then he still insisted
that you give him your number yeah
because like I just want to be friends
or whatever and I but it's like I don't
know you're young and you want the tip
you're being like really nice to you you
don't want to be like no I said no I
don't know now I would do that no I
don't know how did he stalk you that's
what I'm he would call the phone like 50
times a day like 50 times and leave so
many voice mails Easter
I just know that we're supposed to be
together I met this dude once I was
serving his table he couldn't stop
thinking about you I've never had that
and then he would send it's wrong with
me it's and and you couldn't block
numbers on cell phones back then it was
a Nokia brick phone so did he find where
you lived you know we just called you a
liar you I see like a lot that's amazing
like every day and I told my parents but
we couldn't do anything you can't walk
the number or anything pick up and say
I'm not interested in you Oh terrified
but I didn't pick up calling I should
also my mom you called my dog there one
more time I'm going to kill you my dad
has an American accent I forget used to
have an accent he was a kid he got made
fun of and then it got bullied out of
him alright so this story here she's my
daughter
it all started with an Instagram post so
the post here it's white tea medley
would you like to read the caption
okay I'm not even joking here and I'm
not trying to be mean but if I ended up
missing tonight tell the police to find
this woman lol has not stopped following
me around asking me questions and
telling me all about her life since I
got off the stage this evening now it's
social hour and I have a shadow help
hashtag tech stalker hash tag TechCrunch
hashtag my shadow hashtag stalker
hashtag conference speaker 90 comic
problems
this fool is so [ __ ] lame oh my god
he's trying to [ __ ] be like this
fangirl can't get it goes this women guy
so this guy he claims to be a software
developer suppose it we should develop
some of the spell check let's get a wet
over software well why is he on stage
again like what is he doing he claims
that he goes he's a conference speaker
yeah doesn't you the speaker for a
console he does a software groupie
that's what he's exactly but that is a
stop or group that you could figure out
and stuff for you to wear that would be
what you [ __ ] up because he messed
with the wrong girl but she was a
software developer yeah she's actually
in tech really oh [ __ ] someone
recognized her in that photo he was just
picking on her cuz she does that she
looks like that oh no no what now that
she made a bigger look like yeah yeah
because she looks like she could be
pumped you know I mean like you should
just look like a girl that's not gonna
defend herself the way he described I
thought she was gonna be as what I
thought that was him okay I thought that
was him and in those a girl behind there
cuz she's done she's cute yes she is
cute I mean of course it's a girl but
from my distance from my distance yeah
she's like fixed hair you know maybe
that's a girl yes obvious all right
let's move on from her look she's a cute
girl gonna give you guys more she owns
Google know Sony I like nerds
okay her name is Chloe and one of her
followers recognized her and they were
like hey is this you so then she ended
up looking at that and then she read the
caption she was like what the [ __ ] this
so this is a response flat back well I
have been harassed online before but at
T Medellin I have no idea who you are
nor was I add a conference slash
meet-ups slash event with you four days
ago lying about this is next-level also
plus plus photo is from my at new co
article I published years ago slash from
a conference three years ago
get a life yeah so you got this off of
Google so he wasn't even there he wasn't
there and that photos from three years
ago from an article what does she look
like now I didn't get a recent photo
she's [ __ ] hot as [ __ ] now dude she
doesn't look hot
sorry I thought was gonna be her in a
bikini enemy Wow David move on from her
looks the reason why I want to put it
out there is because who the [ __ ] does
he think he is
exactly I haven't even told you the
juice juice yet it tell us the juice I
want the team that wasn't the juice
what's the juice here after all this
happen her followers started digging
into his Instagram
when they do that big big day and what
they found is this so there's so much
like there's not to catch a predator
that's one of them right so on his
Instagram he said my interview in a
global engineering and robotics
publication I actually sound much
smarter than I really am and so it's
this article here in a he photoshopped
his own oh my god the different photo
but his name in like a little bio so it
looks like he's crazy but this is the
real article whoa oh my god that was
just the same photo flipped over oh he's
such a big space it does look like it's
about yeah it does Wow big space alright
so that's one of them right here's
another one
someone found his Facebook page oh my
god I said that he was better not be a
Honda it looks like at Tahoe this is
what the caption says that got
perspective check three years ago today
I'm living proof that miracles still
happen every day if we just open our
eyes to see them Paul Michael wasn't
living through this car totaling
accident but the brain tumor that was
detected when I was sent to the
Hollywood God no signs or side effects
of its existence and the neurosurgeon
said that if I had gone for five more
months without his detection it could
have been too large and inoperable which
means without this accident I would be
haunting several of you right now make
every day count people hashtag blessed
so that's the caption but in reality
this all my crash that involves a 72
year old man and a woman oh my god from
years ago
a loser who literally took an excerpt
out of the office we're [ __ ] Michael
Scott hit Meredith with this car as she
hit turns out she has rabies
exactly that's pretty awesome
this was a life larper inspiration to
people oh my this photo here is that
should be fun everyone was privileged to
see another sunrise like this this
morning but you could just google that
same photo
had a great day in Chapel Hill with
Rachel always been such a dear friend to
me laughs and even more good of a well
whatever but in reality her name is
Julia and I don't know which one he's
talking is he still have an account did
he close it you know what you know first
I was laughing um cause I bet you he
does this to try to impress girls that
he tries to pick up on line look at my
life I'm [ __ ] amazed and he probably
wants to get friends bad for him he just
wants to be an inspiration guy Oh
[ __ ] unaccomplished do you have to be
to fabricate friends he accomplishes
that for creating this fake reality and
overall you understand and then this one
up next teen medellin global leader and
you you and he just put his vision board
all over his instagram instead of
creating a vision board exactly
this is my life this is the real ones
Calvin Klein Wow he's really good at
Photoshop he's claiming like he met Seth
Rogen is that him
he's like throwback Thursday charity
golf tourney and ball in La photoshopped
him well so this is not photoshopped
it's just that Seth Rogen is a [ __ ]
wax statue discovered all of this [ __ ]
so then there's eating this which likes
me
one out of three one to let everyone
know via Twitter and Facebook that my
Instagram account was hacked this week
so if you get a weird friend request
from me or anything that looks out of
place other to please let me know two
out of three while my Instagram was
hacked three images were posted stating
where I was at a conference this week
which was completely false
the third actually accused a young lady
Chloe Condit of apparently stalking me
which is absurd this who's got a lie
about his lies this is awesome this was
a compulsive liar dude I just want to
make this clear that I have never met
Chloe calling on nor have I ever know
nor have I
of her until this morning not sure if my
account was an attack on me personally
or to try and embarrass mrs. condone but
I can assure you that in no way did she
stalk me nor was I at a conference oh I
wanna live friend
that's pretty [ __ ] wild Facebook he
posted on there saying that he believes
it's a past employee or a co-worker what
about those other pictures what if it's
true you want to dress that and he's
also saying that now he's talking to his
lawyer about cyber bullying attacking
him and like draining his children back
yes kids he claimed that he photoshopped
them thank goodness he's claiming Beauty
make corporation as fake employees
that's was a lying sack of [ __ ] in he
got his Twitter here and his Instagram
account which I don't know what it's
real photos I don't know and then so
he's saying that someone else is
stalking Chloe I mean how shitty by the
way is his dog's name is Chloe how she
did you have to be to take a stock photo
of a [ __ ] sunset you don't have
sunsets where you live so [ __ ] true
that's so odd lady he doesn't he's like
not many are blessed to see the sunset
like me I'm not blessed to see sunsets
exist all over the water that's a lot of
[ __ ] water a lot of work cuz there
was this other photo to a huge it was
like go photos this girl and like this
boat in a bikini so you can't see her
face with hands up saying something like
I don't know what she sees in me but do
you look it up and it's a stock oh yeah
this is yep crazy fatigue I need a
psychologist diagnosis on this guy like
what is this even calls this syndrome I
know it loser person like this that
fooled us and booked us for a show back
in the day yeah and he was such a
compulsive liar artist he managed to get
all of these youtubers to go and perform
at this show and didn't pay anybody they
never ended up having money in the first
place they just they were so good at
using one like performer and saying like
they'll vouch for me and then you know
another person vouch for him and it's
like that's like tannic on it was worse
because he didn't even have money in the
first place to begin with
and he was a complete [ __ ] liar like
he just kept lying and lying and lying
and lying and it was like I wanted to
just keep him as a friend so I could see
how much lies they could come up with
for those stories yeah cuz it's funny
this is like some next-level [ __ ]
it is this is like someone that actually
takes a lot of work it does it does
decent photoshopping skills looks like
if you read like if you go to
conventions like where there's
motivational speakers they're like you
have to believe that you're living the
life already you know so maybe this is
was his way of like believing the life
already
I hate with people when they hear like
self helps you and they do [ __ ] it all
up yeah it's like you know what you
gotta visualize your success so all they
do is they talk about how dope they are
but they don't do anything it's like
hold on a second baby miss the message
yes how you make it yeah
[Music]